PROFESSOR: Welcome back to
8.20, special relativity.
In the last section,
we discussed
that moving clocks
tick differently
than those which are at rest.
And here, I would
like to discuss
real life example of this.
The muon is an
elementary particle
very similar to the electron.
It's mass is about
200 times as heavy.
The muon was
discovered in the 1930s
by Anderson and
Neddermeyer at Caltech.
And it's really one of
my favorite particles
because you can--
they are abundant.
There's many of them
in cosmic air showers.
You can study them, you
can study their lifetime.
You can even calculate the
lifetime on a piece of paper.
So what Anderson
and Neddermeyer did
is they just basically
went outside and discovered
a particle which
comes from the sky.
And so they studied
cosmic radiation.
Muons are produced in
cosmic air showers,
and we look at one of
those a little later.
Basically, protons hits
the upper atmosphere,
and in a shower of
various particles,
muons are being produced.
And then those muons are
not stable particles,
but they are stable
enough to reach us.
On average, if you hold
out your hand right now,
about one muon travels through
your hand every second.
How is this possible?
So if you look at this
muon, it gives you
a little bit of particle
physics explanation here.
Again, the muon is
not a stable particle.
They decay via the
weak interaction.
For those who are
interested, this
is a Feynman diagram
for this decay.
The muon couples to the w,
and as a result of the decay,
you find an electron, an
anti-electron neutrino,
and the muon [INAUDIBLE].
The lifetime is about
2.2 microseconds--
2.2 times 10 to the
minus 6 seconds.
And I just taught 8.701
which is introductory class
into particle and
nuclear physics,
and the students
calculated the lifetime
of a muon in that class.
So you can calculate this.
And you need a few tools, but
it's not that hard after all.
The average velocity
of the muons
when they're being produced is
close to the speed of light,
or 0.998 times the
speed of light.
And if you do a
classical calculation,
and you want to figure
out how long do the muons
on average live--
fly, you find that this
is about 660 meters.
Now they are produced
in the upper atmosphere,
and nevertheless, we can
find them down here on Earth.
So something is not quite right.
What is not quite right--
you can already assume--
is that the clock in the
muon as observed by us
ticks much, much slower
than for the muon at rest.
And so the lifetime of the
muon of 2.2 microseconds
is basically extended.
If you calculate this--
this is average velocity--
we find gamma factor of 15.
Using the equation we--
[? of ?] time dilation, you
just simply multiply 15 times
2.2 microseconds, and you
find that muons, indeed,
reach our hand on
the surface of Earth.
This is a really fun example.
Again, you can study
those cosmic showers,
those muons, and
learn about the muons
in very simple experiments.
This picture here shows you one
of those air shower formations.
So the story is a
little bit more complex.
As I explain, this is a
spectacular air shower,
or a picture of
one, where you have
an [INAUDIBLE] coming
in at an energy
of 10 to 15 electronvolts.
And so even its lower energies
show us look like the one here.
It produces, in collision
with the atmosphere,
many, many particles-- pions,
protons, additional protons,
neutrons, and pions again.
And those pions then,
they decay into muons.
And this all happens in
the upper atmosphere,
but also in some
cases, further down.
So here, we have
seen now an example
which you can actually
see and observe
in nature, where particles
travel with high speed.
And there are
relativistic effects
we can measure and observe.